oh you mean you put a pillow over your
mouth
do you like choke me or something it's a
sexy thing noise this telling I wake up
oh no I'll just be quiet no you're not
freaking out about having a second kid
three how do you finding mommy still
though we really got to gather some
dolls doesn't miss pinky want some tea
we didn't really sell yet in 30 days if
everything goes well you close
descending leather fraternity doesn't
move in next door you're gonna be fine
hi we're your neighbors welcome to our
sorority
I can't believe a [ __ ] sorority move
next door I don't even talk to those
girls nothing what now Bo Peep nadu it
is not that early usually quiet family
take hard drugs and they're much smarter
the buyers could come by at any moment
and see the 20 psychopathic teenagers
next door we need somebody who can
relate the stupid young people let's
shut this [ __ ] down that's right I'm
switching sides if we steal their stash
they won't be able to pay the rent
what's the plan I'm gonna dance just few
dancing is enough to distract the entire
sorority do you want me to celebrities
you called our parents dad what is this
what happened to my little girl it's
really not a big deal this is a very big
deal you turned it on we turned it off
this isn't working it's a little hard to
call tops without a phone
give us that back yup oh it's called a
cork dumbass
that's our way out
the blast from this airbag will propel
us straight through that vent time to
save my family car drugs and they're
much smarter